so che in passato hai sofferto tanto e
ti ho fatto soffrire però tu metti tutto
questo è per questo che oggi sono qui
patti
dopo aver pensato a lungo sulla nostra
situazione e ho capito una cosa ho
capito che senza di te non ce la posso
fare
tu il tuo parecchio i tuoi occhi che
fatica che sta distinguere un altro culo
mi mancheranno ma se la cosa più
importante
avete avuto nella mia intera vita buddy
io ti amo il ti chiedo perdono tutti ti
prego abbracciami si perdono si cioè io
lo scoprirà a capirle entrare in
sintonia con lei da su jessica cambi
canale selena va bertuzza n'è tornata
ottimo poiché dovrà vedersela con me
perché sono ciano gas park e basta
cenere
sai io sono certo basso anno ecco qual è
il tuo problema perché continua ad
odiarmi perché predetto la mia fiducia
di migliore amica la mi dispiace per
quello che ho fatto me ne pento
non posso tornare indietro forse avresti
potuto fare qualcosa di diverso invece
di scappare via
è il senso di colpa per essermi fatta il
cane del vicino e la teiera di mia madre
era voi lo saremo
l'orgoglio non va bene questo non lo
posso vedere posso cambiarlo guarda
maria i miei genitori mi hanno insegnato
che devo seguire cuore di alibec che
anche se però criticata se col cuore uno
sempre fatto fino adesso e cerco polonio
vabbè basta ma che è una critica quella
ora c'è ma non ti ama lo possono
permettere che a me no quota oggi non è
proprio giornata
ma già il fatto che non le possiamo
vedere queste cose siamo troppo
sensibile no infatti sarà questo caso
non ne posso vedere di polonio brava a
scema no quello che voglio dire che non
capisco perché questi cuori teneri e
sensibile non avere un minimo di
contatto col mondo reale si è stato un
colpo duro durissimo un colpo veramente
insostenibile per gli abitanti di questa
ormai ex splendida cittadella alla
mattina del 25 luglio quando invece di
essere svegliati dalla solita sveglia
sono stati mamma ho deciso di farmi il
piercing al cervello
finalmente una bella notizia ma era una
cittadella proprio belle ci sono stata 4
botti e air a bella
e ora non c'è più la città della bella
ma ora lo so però c'è forse il signor
pace ma che fa il ciad ha scelto di
perde la verginità 2 andata non lo so
non sento questo di moda o cioè mille
posso andare in media che sono ancora
peggio è questa se chiaro e senti di
soros scegli tu quello che vuoi fare
della vita cioè il fondo sarà abbastanza
grande
non lo so vorrei tanto essere popolare
ma non so come potrà veramente in piedi
uno scandalo scolastico
mi sembra una buona idea tipo farmela
con il prof inibendo la scuola sono da
interpretare un attimo
beh cosa succede sto morendo paura dica
al pubblico quanta paura interessare
alle famiglia senza un padre attento che
l'angelo della morte si avvicina ci
spieghi come è fatto questo angelo lo
spieghi alle persone a casa è tipo un po
alto ecco gli occhi tunnel di luce boia
non taglia maniera ragione
abbiamo assistito alla morte di certo
che ci stanno tante nei gradi in
italiano
comunque dicevi che scandalo vuoi fare
se infatti adesso mi sta diventando
quindi ma siamo noi che non abbiamo più
metro di giudizio per capire cosa è
serio o sono loro che invece ci hanno
fatto venire il calo emotivo
propinandoci ogni porta la solita roba
per fare gossip e notizie piuttosto che
per informare